be Fearless change is
good I don't really care if I sleep too
much it's kind of fun to see how much
one can do in a day I want to look
pretty but not too made up not that I
ever look very made
up I was able to turn the things I
really liked to do into a really
thriving business I like that this one
yeah I started my company when I was 50
years
old my work is based on need and want
it's extremely powerful to take an idea
and turn it into a billion dooll
business this is what I want to look
like that is my look hard work is
essential to making an idea come to life
and I love hard workers that is such a
cake if you can find somebody that's
going to be as good or better than you
embrace them and bring them in that's
the one I Chu and how much GHC was in
that one I got 1 milligram I want to put
you to sleep people always say oh you
reinvent yourself I try to look
forward when you're through changing
you're
through I'm artha Stewart and this is
Master
[Music]
Class